à rome tous les trains mais n'a terminé
terminé c'est la plus grande gare
d'italie cinq cent mille personnes y
transitent quotidiennement paumé au
coeur de la foule une centaine de
voyageurs sans valise ils sont tunisiens
aient fui leur pays une tunisie libérée
de la dictature mais dont l'économie est
à genoux une seule solution chercher un
job en europe pour les aider ici aucune
structure d'urgence heureusement deux
jeunes femmes viennent briser l'errance
[Musique]
a dit l'un d'eux chauffe eau via les
icones chinois multi canal et quels
médias thomas match nul à contrôler
comme cela a eu lieu rue doit se faire
cela et où m sont des aiguilles euse
providentiel elles sont tunisiennes ont
tout juste la vingtaine et ont grandi à
rome l'une est traductrice l'autre
étudiante ému par l'exil massif de leurs
compatriotes infligée par le dead dont
ils bénéficient en italie elles ont
décidé de prendre les choses en main
elles savent mieux que personne qu'elle
des contenus attend ici leurs frères
tunisiens
regardent ce jeune homme
regarde un peu
et doit avoir 17 18 ans qui lui a donné
de l'argent ses parents il l'envoie
directement à la mort nous on veut dire
à leur maman arrêté arrêté
utilisez plutôt cet argent pour monter
des projets en tunisie
pour ces jeunes tunisiens le début du
périple c'est la chute du régime ben ali
[Musique]
la tunisie c'est le point de départ du
printemps arabe quatre semaines
d'insurrection qui ont démoli 25 ans de
dictature le 17 décembre 2010 dans le
centre du pays mohamed bouazizi un
marchand dont la police confie ce que
les produits s'immole par le feu
s'ensuivent manifestations et grèves
générales aux cris de ben ali dégage
toute la tunisie est dans la rue le 14
janvier 2011 le dictateur jette l'épongé
et s'enfuit en arabie saoudite
sur les ruines de la révolution de
jasmin les défis sont immenses installer
une démocratie endiguer la corruption et
surtout relancer l'économie en 2011 le
taux de chômage a littéralement explosé
il devrait atteindre les 20 % la liberté
fraîchement acquise ne nourrit pas du
coup plus de 25 mille tunisiens ont déjà
choisi l'exil européen
pour eux la porte d'entrée de l'europe
c'est l'italie avant d'échouer à rome
tous les jeunes de termini ont pris la
voie des mers est accosté en sicile ou à
l'amp et 12 ha où le traverser à haut
risque et des conditions d'arrivée
inhumaines
ont crevé en ont pas tous ont crevé à
trapani mais vous savez pas comment on a
fait la file pour manger ces axes
incroyable et hello hello qui coupait
chaque jour j'ai 26 ans moi j'ai débuté
en vision de la envie de voir
d'argent pour
dimanche famille pour
envoyer mon père et ma mère
jalabert
l'italie leur a donné un permis de
séjour provisoire et un titre de voyage
ses papiers leur ouvre les portes de
l'europe en attendant que la tunisie se
redresse
[Musique]
les exilés tunisiens n'auront vu de rome
que sa gare est sa préfecture c'est ici
que ce matin les la williams et quelques
amis emmène ceux qui n'ont pas encore
leurs papiers pour les échoués de
termini pas question de quitter rome
sans ses papiers en poche ils sont
ballottés dans la tourmente
administrative d'un pays dont il ne
parle pas la langue
[Musique]
comment tu t'appelles
note tous les noms pour faciliter le
travail des inspecteurs à l'intérieur
vu qu'on ne peut pas rentrer avec un
interprète on donne les noms et les
prénoms pour les relevés d'empreintes
digitales
objectif pour tous le permis de séjour
provisoire le temps que la démocratie en
tunisie tienne ses promesses
démocrate et match 20 octobre à
[Musique]
ses parents par a détalé c'est pas
l'argent qui volent aux lèvres
gc ca mais il y a des chances et lueur
d'espoir
j'ai des faits
j'ai cherché laisse coi
[Musique]
l'espoir et la réussite ahmed à fiennes
en est le symbole pour ce beau gosse
tunisien la ville éternelle c'est la
dolce vita comédien célèbre en tunisie
l'a conquis en moins de quatre ans le
choeur des romains au point d'être le
premier artiste étranger nominé aux
donatello les césars italien il n'en
perd pas pour autant le contact avec la
petite communauté des tunisiens de rome
[Musique]
ce local c'est le siège de l'association
des tunisiens de la ville tous sont
installés à rome depuis plusieurs années
mais ils n'ont jamais vraiment décrocher
du pays la révolution ne les a pas
surpris et ils n'y sont pas pour rien
l'arnaqué géoloc l'année de l'étoile
wolf a relaté
facebook
la
prophétie et sa dictature échoué à tenir
en équilibre one trois majors parisiens
qui est qu'ils ont pas vécu sur le
terrain
cette révolution ils ont quelque chose
qui manque parce que ces choses qui se
passent une seule fois dans la vie et on
n'a pas participé si ça fait mal au
coeur quand même aucun cependant ne se
dit prêt à rentrer tout de suite en
tunisie le pays est trop fragile tous
comprennent les jeunes compatriotes qui
débarque sur les côtes italiennes et
dont la télé fait le recensement
quotidien
coup
de maître en tout cas dit peter solberg
au meeting et enel food in flames
mikka le mouvement de solidarité et les
manges haut débit la bd
[Musique]
la solidarité tunisienne heureusement
elle existe aussi à rome au tour a
terminé avec ahmed à la gare toujours la
même rengaine la même confusion le même
désoeuvrement et au milieu toujours
leïla et oui m
[Musique]
l'exode des tunisiens qualifiées de
bibliques par rome à créer des tensions
avec paris et bruxelles au point de
remettre en cause le principe de libre
circulation dans l'espace schengen
en quel honneur
et
tous ces jeunes le disent ils
retourneront en tunisie lorsque le
printemps arabe aura porté ses fruits
pour la gare de termini c'est le début
de la route ils iront vers d'autres
qu'est français probablement là bas
parmi les 600 mille tunisiens de france
les attend peut être un cousin une soeur
désormais les naufragés de la gare
romaine le savent où qu'ils aillent ils
ne peuvent compter que sur eux mêmes et
une poignée de compatriotes